ma cousine c'est pas ma copine je le dis
on sait jamais ça peut intéresser les
gens c'est un beau garçon sympathique
intelligent
elle n'a que des qualités il pense qu'on
est marié et ça ça me fait du tort
charles est un personnage qui est qui et
naïve qui est simple qui qui qui dit
tout ce qu'elle ressent de charles et
dino le grand public connaît leur prénom
et leur état civil souvent répété ils ne
sont que cousins cousines leurs sketches
son burlesque dans la tradition du music
hall
mais l'humour a aussi son exigence il y
a eu un vrai travail de comedia pour
créer ce couple
c'est un travail qu'on a fait au père du
soleil qu'ariane mnouchkine sur les
personnages on a beaucoup appris sur
cette idée qu'il faut pas les faire il
faut pas les inventer ou pas les
imaginer il faut les recevoir
jean les 6 à 3 tu ne t'es pas détaché tu
n'as pas disparu je mets ça fait quinze
ans que dino hauspie charlet ou
inversement
jusqu'à présent leurs chamailleries été
discrète à l'abri de petits cabarets
aujourd'hui elles s'étalent au grand
jour devant les 1000 spectateurs d'une
salle parisienne
mais il paraît que la consécration ne
change rien à la faire mieux mieux et
mieux qu'il ya plus de monde et une
expression qui dit plus de riz non non
mais fous plus on rit parfois aussi
poète charles et dino nous renvoie
surtout à la nostalgie de l'adolescence
[Musique]